my name is Joe gall I'm at the kind
institution in Baltimore the Department
of embryology and I'm going to
about in situ hybridisation in situ
hybridisation is the technique by which
a labeled single-stranded RNA or DNA
molecule in solution is hybridized to
immobilize two single-stranded RNA or
DNA in a tissue or tissue section and by
having a tag on the molecule in solution
eventually the hybrid is visible in the
tissue section as you'd through a
microscope this technique of in situ
hybridization was first carried out
successfully in my laboratory in 1968
the origin of in situ hybridization at
least as an intellectual phenomenon
derives from experiments that have been
carried out much earlier mainly around
1950 by two investigators named Coons
and Kaplan and what Coons and Kaplan had
done was to develop the technique of
immuno Saito chemistry a technique by
which a fluorescent antibody was made to
bind to the antigen immobilized in a
tissue section so that one could detect
the position of specific protein
molecules in cells by their fluorescence
and shown here is a modern image this is
a nuclear body from us of salamander oil
site here shows immunostaining with the
protein with an antibody against the
protein Corrin here's immunostaining
with an antibody against an SM protein
this is a slide which I made more
recently using the Coons and Kaplan
technique the point however is that they
had shown that it was possible to detect
specific protein molecules in tissues
and it occurred to me that it would be
wonderful if one could detect specific
nucleic acids in tissues actually I was
thinking less about nucleic
asses as I was thinking about jeans
because I'd been studying the giant
chromosomes and salamanders shown here
or the giant chromosomes of Joseph was
shown here and in these chromosomes one
can see bands that were pretty much
regarded as genes by people working with
them at that time we now know there's a
little bit more complicated than that
but it seemed that we had here a tissue
a chromosome where specific genes
specific nucleic acids it should be
possible to do something comparable to
the immunofluorescent staining technique
to detect and specific genes in these
tissues so actually I kept this in my
mind for quite a long time and it became
possible to think about doing this kind
of thing in the early 1960s when
investigators discovered that one could
take double-stranded DNA
denature it into a single strands and
immobilize those strands on a
nitrocellulose nitrocellulose filter
this was done by a couple of
investigators named Gillespie and
Spiegelman and what they showed was that
having the denatured DNA on a filter one
could then hybridize radioactive RNA to
it and actually determined and
quantitatively the amount of a
particular gene sequence on the filter
so I thought I I thought well if they
can do it on a filter you ought to be
able to do it on a slide so I tried
denaturing the DNA on a slide that is in
cells nuclei that were squashed out onto
a slide and I found that I could be
nature the DNA quite adequately
without damaging the tissue but then
when I tried to hybridize a radioactive
RNA to it I got no signal in this case I
was
looking for the radioactivity by
autoradiography that is by covering the
tissue with a thin layer of photographic
emulsion and looking for silver grains
in the emulsion caused by the
radioactivity of the probe as I said
nothing happened and I more or less gave
up on that a technique that was in the
early to mid-1960s
now a break came quite accidentally from
studies that I and others have been
carried out had been carrying out on
salamander oocytes
and frog oil sites and what we found was
that in the giant [ __ ] site nucleus
which is shown here derived from this
large oil site here the oocyte is the
egg of the frog inside of this giant
nucleus are of course the chromosomes
but in addition we found that there were
several hundred to a thousand nuclei
these round bodies here shown on this
particular slide now the interesting
thing about these nuclei that we
discovered was that they contained DNA
and it was specifically the genes that
code for ribosomal RNA that were in
these nuclei this is a most unusual
situation to have DNA outside of the
chromosomes but it was quite clear from
work that had been carried out in my
laboratory as well as in the laboratory
of Don Brown and of Oscar Miller that
there was extra chromosomal DNA outside
in these in the clear life and I studied
the origin of that DNA and what I found
was that it actually has was synthesized
at one specific time in the early
history of the formation of the oocyte
and one could see in these early cells
early nuclei that there was a cap
of DNA here and you can see the tap over
here you can see the chromosomes here
and down here you can see the
chromosomes in this nucleus so there's
in these two nuclei you have the
chromosome but then you have this huge
cap of extra DNA which in fact was the
ribosomal genes that had been somehow
and somehow come out of the chromosome
and amplified to give you this one
specific sequence a very large amount of
this one specific sequence so it
occurred to me that if there was any
possibility of doing in situ
hybridization this was the case that
would work and so I took a radioactive
ribosomal RNA and hybridized it to the
cells of this sort and I was quite
pleased to see the very first
experiments that we got good in situ
hybridization here this cell is black
because of the silver grains in the
photographic emulsion that have been
exposed by the radioactivity of the
hybridizing probe so this is a case
where we have hybridized radioactive RNA
ribosomal RNA to the ribosomal DNA in
the cell so that led immediately to a
publication with my student Mary Lou
Purdue who joined me with this in this
work and this was the first successful
in situ hybridization now we wanted to
try it on some other tissue or DNA but
there were very few examples because at
that time it was not possible to isolate
a specific DNA RNA sequences what
permitted us to look at another
situation came from studies that had
been carried out
on mouse DNA and investigators had found
that when Mouse DNA was spun in a
caesium chloride gradient it separated
into two fractions a main peak and a
satellite peak
called satellite simply because it had a
slightly different density and separated
from the bulk of the DNA we took this
satellite DNA made it a radioactive and
we hybridized it to mouse chromosomes
not knowing at all whether it would
hybridize but it was even in the
chromosomes for that matter it might
have been a virus or some other
infecting particle but we were very
pleased to see that the mouse satellite
DNA hybridized specifically to one
portion of each chromosome and you can
see on this slide that each of the
chromosomes has a bit of great activity
at the very end of the chromosome this
region of the chromosome was known as
the heterochromatin and had been known
psychologically as a specific region of
the chromosome for a number of years
this let us immediately to think that we
should be able to try the same technique
yet similar results looking at the
chromosomes of drosophila and the
chromosomes of drosophila were
especially exciting because it was known
from genetics that the genes were all in
the so called euchromatic regions of the
chromosome namely this region from here
to here or over here these lighter
stained regions all of the genes were
located in those regions and it was
known from genetics that the
heterochromatic regions like here
and here were devoid of genes so it
occurred to us that drosophila must have
a lot of a DNA similar to the satellite
DNA of the mouse so we centrifuge that
DNA in a cesium chloride gradient and
and found indeed that drosophila had a
lot of satellite DNA the species of
Drosophila virilis that we were working
on had three huge satellite peaks he
here here in addition to the main peak
of DNA shown here so we took this
satellite DNA we made it radioactive we
hybridized it to the chromosomes and
sure enough it hybridized as shown of
these images here to the heterochromatic
regions and this was particularly
interesting as I said because it showed
that the heterochromatic regions that we
knew from genetics had no genes
consistent of this satellite type DNA
which are later studies showed consisted
of very simple sequences which were
incapable of coding form genes were
incapable of being genes and coding for
proteins so the in situ hybridization
technique at this point was limited
pretty much to sequences that were
present in large amounts in cells
eventually it became possible by having
more and more sensitive probes and
particularly later techniques were
worked out for making fluorescent probes
to do in situ hybridization so in situ
hybridization is a chore ich became
fluorescent in situ hybridization or
fish fi SH which is the way it's usually
practiced now and the techniques have
gotten more and more sensitive to the
point where nowadays it's possible to
detect individual single DNA and RNA
molecules in tissue sections
you